how are you guys doing
good good great man amazing
okay so help me out with the neighbors a
party party humor alcohol right can you
run me through quickly the the
translation uh of this and the story
behind it
um this this actually this name actually
came out after um
like five of them because we were we
were like debating which one we should
use um because of certain illegal stuff
um but this one we we thought that would
be cool for everybody because it's kind
of like an empowerment for for women it
is an apartment for our women you know
so
um we kind of just wanted them to have
this this song and just you know use it
for themselves whenever they're going
through a bad relationship or a bad
breakup that they don't really need that
bad breakup or that man whatever that
they need to be able to be empowered
empowered and also every it goes for
everybody as well
you know you don't even when men can
relate to you exactly men can relate you
don't need that significant other to be
happy you could just go out you know
have a drink you know dance and just
listen to the song and just have a good
time
so where did this come from uh was it
was it something that you had seen going
on uh was this from friends who had been
talking to you like where did the sort
of idea of doing this song for for those
people come from
i mean it's nothing it's nothing that
have like we've seen by and we've gone
through this yeah i mean we've gone
through but
as we just wanted to give this to the
fans like to our fans because we know
cnc owners are there like they're the
lawyers the lawyer lawyers loyalists
loyalists
it's the first time i said that word
the first time i worked
so that i think they're the best fandom
if possible so we just wanted to give
that song to them and the majority of
our fans is
women so you know you kind of want to
dedicate them this to them
understandably uh when it comes to the
sound there's a very you know that 80s
sort of vibe is really popular right now
what made you guys sort of go into that
direction where did that inspiration
come from
i mean experimenting new sounds
um
you know we've been trying to experiment
for a while different sounds and and a
lot of stuff we're kind of known for
that especially fashion as well um so we
just wanted to have this time that we
are more in control of where our you
know career and on top of everything you
know um we're a little bit more involved
in everything all the creatives so we
just wanted to be uh be able to express
ourselves musically and and
and fashion wise and any type of visual
that we wanted to create and give our
fans something different that they
haven't heard from cnco or seen from
cnco
yeah and having that sort of or
freedom that you know that creative
input um how hard did you guys fight for
that and how important was that to you
to be able to just continually put more
and more and more of yourselves into the
tracks
i mean it's
it's not hard it was not hard it's just
it's just that we just let
let it flow because we didn't have the
knowledge to be i'm still learning about
that
you learn every every day about
everything you know about every aspect
of your career and every aspect of what
you're doing but at the beginning it was
just like
we
we just enter into this world of
possibilities you know and there's
another people that been here for 20 30
years and we just came in so we're just
going to let them leave for now but
right now we're completely like maybe
six years and a half as a boyfriend
as a group and and i think we know what
we want and and where we're going you
know right now is where the time that we
feel more connected to each other feel
more grounded and and
have to have a clearer vision of where
you want to go yeah
and that sound i mean you look at
somebody like the weekend an artist like
the weekend where he's really wrapped
his identity around that kind of retro
uh vibe do you guys have a list like a
dream list of people that you would love
to sort of jump on a track with or
collaborate with
oh of course
i mean the weekend is one of the best
facts
um but we have daddy
uh you know drake chris brown
you know uh nothing else yeah nobody you
know
a bunch of people yeah a bunch of people
uh we're just open for great music at
the end of the day yeah that's great
music
and you guys had mentioned earlier that
the vast majority of your fans are women
what's it like going out can you guys
actually go and enjoy a night out like
you sing about like can you go to a club
and not be sort of like bothered and not
be the band
i mean we all depends on the country too
like let's say in america is a little
tougher you know because most of our
fandom is from latin america uh but you
know we can still go i'll enjoy the
drink here and there you know we still
have fun
yeah we have a lot of fun
who would be who in the band who in the
band goes the hardest who goes the
hardest who goes the hardest
i think we have our days
we have our days we have our days but
there's there's one that's not here that
he's the one that a little bit part
parties
he's the one that goes on
and uh if one of you if one of you is
going to if one of you is going to pack
it in early one night who's that
okay
if if
somebody if one of you if
who in the band is the most likely to go
to bed early to skip on partying oh
um
it depends like it will be either
or me
yeah
i mean everybody to be honest i think it
depends on the thing
yeah it depends on what you're doing
yeah exactly
who's around
[Laughter]
a lot of variations
and uh
what is this uh talk me through the
disney plus show what is this
so we have
we have uh we've been in like one month
i'm recording this this tv show that
we dreamed for so long and finally we
are um
um
we're doing it you know um
and it's
we pray that we
want you guys um
like yeah
already you know it's just a show
um that kind of defines a like a kind of
disney vibe of a boy band you know um
and who's the best and uh actual boy
band
you know so it would be super cool to
um
kind of relate to the characters a
little bit and certain things and and
play new new roles and play different
you know characters and meet new people
meet new people from that industry of
actors and stuff like that first the
first time you guys are gonna see cnc
exactly
yeah i was gonna i was gonna say who
took to acting the best who's the uh
who's the actor of the group that had no
problem
not then we all put our thank you but
our best you know we all did it it's our
first time acting so i think we all
tried as best as we could you know to
make this flow and make this you know
the best that we can for our fans and
for everybody out there
what was it like when you guys have done
the shows you have and have had the
success that you have to get into acting
and maybe do something that made you a
little bit nervous for the first time in
i don't know how long was that a good
feeling
hard it was heavy but it's hard it's
nice because you take out of your
comfort zone so it's like you learn
new stuff you know it's a new challenge
so it's super refreshing to like do
stuff like that but we watched it we're
scared definitely yeah we were like i
was super scared
yeah
and uh before i let you go uh what can
fans what can fans expect what uh what
do you guys have coming up what can they
expect it shows anybody who's sort of
curious about you right now what can
they expect from the band i mean we have
a bunch of things coming this year we
this year is expected to be our one of
the best years that we have you know
uh we're coming with music we come with
a new album i think well we don't have
dates so we don't we don't i don't want
to say dates because we don't have
nothing confirmed but we have an album
coming a single comment we got a lot of
shows here we are we're coming along
we're going to south america for a lot
of shows around all the cities that
we've been also you guys our first show
our first show is going to be a march
11th in dr dr
that's awesome uh gentlemen thank you so
very much congratulations on everything
thank you so much